estas casas improvisadas y sin terminar
están ubicadas en la ciudad de durán en
la provincia del guayas barrios como
éste han sido objetivos del narcotráfico
para reclutar a jóvenes para vender
drogas esta líder comunitaria de la zona
sueña con que esto acaba verso con los
jóvenes de aquí inclusive trato de
motivarlos a que ellos puedan decirle no
a cualquier cosa que les vengan a
proponer no pero si ustedes recuerda
unos meses atrás un muerto aquí atrás en
panorama y otro muerto acá afuera por
poligráfica por multi metales entonces
de qué estamos hablando durán es la
ciudad más grande del país de este cerro
sale una de las bandas criminales más
temidas los choneros y su brazo armado
los chones killers involucrados en las
últimas masacres carcelarias donde han
sido asesinados unos 400 presos desde el
2021 según las autoridades estas
organizaciones al margen de la ley deben
alrededor de 18 millones de dólares por
la venta de droga sólo en esta ciudad
donde de los 230 detenidos en lo que va
del año y la zona la mayoría tenía entre
17 y 18 años la presencia policial se ha
convertido en algo normal para las
personas que viven aquí
es un sitio estratégico
los criminales para el consumo y el
expendio de microtráfico es decir esto
generaba economías importantes para las
estructuras y por eso eran las disputas
y en estas disputas tuvieron una gran
cantidad de personas que fueron
asesinadas y decapitadas incluso aquí en
cero a raíz de la intervención en cero
las cabras no hemos vuelto te vamos a
tener muertes violentas en el lugar para
las organizaciones de derechos humanos
el problema es más profundo está
criminalizando constantemente a la
pobreza por todo el fallo estructural
que tiene el estado entonces al derivar
la responsabilidad a temas como
narcotráfico bandas se están quitando
justamente
valga la redundancia la responsabilidad
que tienen de crear programas adecuados
acceso a educación acceso a servicios
básicos y mejores condiciones para toda
la sociedad varias organizaciones de
derechos humanos han condenado la
violencia desatada en el país
principalmente por las masacres en las
cárceles como la alta comisionada de la
onu michelle bachelet quien instó al
gobierno una reforma carcelaria urgente